[Music]
today we cancel
scarlett johansson uh she's doing the
media rounds to promote her new
superhero movie which
is i believe the 94th film in the marvel
extended universe
interestingly enough even though it has
produced so many movies it turns out
that this universe is quite small
because all of the movies are
exactly the same they all have the same
basic plot
and action sequences and message not to
spoil anything but the message for all
of these movies
to summarize is bad guy is bad
punch bad guy kick bad guy good guy win
the end now buy the merchandise
that's basically the message um and the
point of all these movies now
i may be selling marvel a little short
here because sometimes the movies do
have a deeper message which brings us to
scarlett johansson
and her interview with glamour magazine
she was asked about the deeper themes
and messages of her new film black widow
which is a movie about an attractive
woman in a leather jumpsuit kicking
people
at least that's what that's what it's
about on the surface but what is the
film
really saying what is it truly trying to
convey
about the nature of kicking and
jumpsuits
and hot blonde chicks joe hansen
trying to explain well i do think the
film
is inherently female be partly
because of kate shortland directing it
it definitely has um
you know it sheds light on
it sheds light on a
you know um on an imbalance i think that
uh women feel like inherently
because of how our society is
has been forever thousands and thousands
of years
and um you know the movie is
about the subjugation of women and
um you know the trauma that uh
we have to help one another out of
oh okay now to be fair to scarlet here
the actual question she was asked
verbatim this was a question
how important is it to push the
conversation around gendered superheroes
that question doesn't mean anything she
was apparently being interviewed by a
random progressive buzzword generator
so she did her best to to take the
discussion to some place that was
moderately intelligible
but she was hobbled again by the fact
that the movie she's promoting is
incredibly bad and stupid and exists
almost entirely
as a vehicle to sell toys and promote
the brand
that's all marvel movies marvel movies
are made by algorithms not people
i would respect her if she just said
that but she can't so instead she
reaches for some kind of socially
conscious
message and she kept reaching in
response to the next question
which was again verbatim what have you
been your own when have you been your
own
ally the most that was the question when
have you been
your own ally the most so once again the
question makes no sense
but here's what she said oh my gosh yeah
i think you have to be
all but that's as a woman you have to be
all the time
um you know because we are
under minded and underserved and under
appreciated and underpaid and you have
to be your own ally
um you know my mom instilled that in me
for when i was
really really young um because of course
she'd experienced it even more severely
than i
than i did and you know equal pay is a
huge part of
of that fight um when i even when i was
a teenager in the industry or a young
woman i should say my mom
you know would have those conversations
like
what why is she not getting you know
that it had never had anything to do
and there was always these these like
these little key terms like um you know
bank ability
and you know box office draw and those
are all
uh way those are all terms that are
basically masquerading
as sexism
okay um
undermined underserved underappreciated
underpaid
this poor woman i might have to start
another gofundme i'm thinking
she can barely make ends meet she's on
the verge of starvation nobody
appreciates her
or serves or pays her this is a real
problem i saw
scarlett johansson out on a street
corner just the other day huddled under
a blanket with a jar full of coins
uh you know it it well i think it was
scarlet hands it might have been
might have been just a drunk guy i don't
know but consider this and get ready to
burst into tears when you hear this
scarlett johansson only makes
about 50 million dollars a year at least
that's what she earned in 2019
only 50 million dollars this is a real
life handmaid's tale this is the
patriarchy plain as day
we are living in a country where a woman
can only make
50 million dollars in a calendar year
now you might say that 50 million
dollars is quite a lot of money you
might say that scarlett johansson
rich beautiful famous beloved not
beloved by me especially but by other
people
um you might say that she should simply
be happy and grateful because life has
granted her all of the material
blessings
a person can ever hope to be given
but the problem for johansson is that
although she has so much
still other people have more yes she
makes a ton of money off of her
marvel films but male action heroes male
action stars
make two tons of money they make even
more
and it must be because of sexism she
says yes it must
or maybe women in hollywood
generally get paid less still a lot
but less because the movies that make
all the money
are action movies especially superhero
movies and those kinds of movies
are more successful that is more people
watch them they sell more tickets they
get more downloads on streaming
when they star men in other words male
stars get
paid more because they're worth more in
terms of pure dollars and cents
the the daily wire article reporting on
this story gives the example of the two
most recent films
starring new superheroes in the marvel
cinematic universe black panther and
captain marvel
the former earned 700 million
domestically while the latter earned 427
million
the former was led by a man the latter
by a woman and these are that's
generally how these things go
why well i think it's because audiences
in general mostly prefer to see
men in these kinds of roles
most members of the audience would never
say that because they can't say that
but the box office speaks for itself
um generally that's what the audience
wants
the studios and hollywood that's not
what they want that's not what they want
us to want
as an audience but it is what the
audience wants part of that is because
the studios
why are the the female action movies and
superhero movies less popular
part of that is because the studios
can't help but inject a bunch of cringy
girl power stuff
into the female action movies and so
audiences are turned off by that while
the
the male action movies will just be
action movies
but also part of it is that men most of
the time from the audience's perspective
make more compelling and convincing
action heroes
perhaps it's mentally exhausting for the
audience to watch a 112 pound blonde
woman
in this kind of role because you have to
strain a bit to take the movie seriously
when she's beating up like 14 armed
thugs at once
you don't have to strain quite as much
watching like the rock do the same
even though it's fiction in both cases
i'm just speculating here
whatever the reason the fact is that
these sorts of movies when there is a
man in the starring role tend to perform
better
audiences tend to be more interested so
those stars get paid a little more
it's not sexism it's economics
and that's why i must say to scarlett
johansson not because she's a woman
but just because she's a whiny entitled
narcissist
you are canceled hey listen
hit the subscribe button do it right now
i
demand it and i thank you for your
compliance it is somewhat
appreciated